hey you get over here
oh i know what it is you're afraid
because i'm the big bad wolf
the villain of every story
and this is the crew mr angela mr shark
mr piranha mr snake everyone copy copy
copy
we're the bad guys it's crime time baby
shark we need a distraction do i get to
improvise fine please be subtle
i'm having a baby
is there a doctor or perhaps several
security guards that could leave that
post and help me
we were never given a chance to be
anything more than criminals but these
are the cars we've been dealt so we
might as well play them
here let me help you
are you okay ma'am thank you dear you're
such a good boy wait what i'm the bad
guy
all good brother oh good yeah yeah
you ever wonder what it'd be like if the
world wasn't scared of us never gonna
happen guys we're gonna go good
did you get hit on the head you villains
have an image problem you need a
makeover
so
no well there goes our street cred well
i'm tired of being an outcast maybe i
don't want to be a what a bad guy you're
going to have to choose between your
friends or the good life they're the
only friends i have ever had you have a
chance to write your own story what have
you got to lose i don't know my dignity
yeah well that ship has already sailed
so you're a tough guy i like it really
rough guys that is an animal testing
lamp with helpless guinea pigs i'll
rescue them you've never volunteered for
anything
oh
come on snake open up relax these doors
are complicated
are you kidding me we're supposed to
save them not eat them well i'd say
they've gone to a better place
[Music]
guys
[Music]